we have a Vash the Stampede statue yeah
and you were like I should draw him what
yeah oh yeah I used to draw all the time
when I was younger like I my dad
basically put an end to it he was like
you're not gonna make money
yeah I literally but that's all I did
when I was in high school of just sit
down math class I was just a draw right
on my notebook and this is before you
actually watch try on right no no this
is well I just watched the Remake I just
started watching it right but yeah I had
seen Snippets of Trigon I never actually
watched anime but I thought it was so
sick like I thought the characters look
so cool yeah yeah that does look cool
yeah the ash is like such a sick looking
character I love the gun and then also
the the cross gun too the rail oh yeah
wolf Woods one yeah yeah so I would
literally draw characters from Trigon
all the time without actually ever
watching it yeah but recently I watched
it and it's so good yeah yeah it's one
of the especially if you're watching the
Remake it's one of the few 3D anime that
actually look really [__] good as
well they use the 3D really really well
on that and it's like full 3d which is
unique you know because the last time I
saw a full 3D anime I think I swore off
anime for good it was the berserk
I'm sorry I'm sorry I think I'm good I'm
Never Gonna Wanna Walk
do you not only watch the 3D anime you
watch probably one of the worst oh yeah
yeah yeah I know literally starting at
the bottom yeah oh my God
Oh
I thought there was like a segment on
the podcast
[Laughter]
okay thanks all right
um yeah like uh I mean obviously they
use assets like they do 3D
backgrounds and things like that yeah
and you know you can Tastefully put that
in there sometimes but this is like
full-blown CGI exactly and I wasn't
expecting much from it and I casually
downloaded it right before the flight
and then instead of watching One Piece I
literally watched all of the all of the
episodes uh that was so good oh I
haven't finished it yet but yeah yeah
yeah I mean Trigon I think is I I don't
know I I had in my mind I wasn't sure if
it aged well but watching the Remake I'm
like okay this is a banger story a
banger setting as well not a
continuation no it's a remake remake
yeah right from the beginning yeah so
you can watch it as well I've already
watched the first one oh okay okay I
remember I had a very weird ending
though yeah yeah 80s ending yeah yeah I
won't unspoiled it obviously because I I
just legit don't know yeah speaking of
not aging well okay I got some anime
takes
you've never seen you so excited okay
first of all this is this is gonna be
contentious okay yeah Dragon Ball Z it
does not age well oh the anime yeah yeah
absolutely okay good yeah
I thought you guys were gonna fight me
on this because like I talk about this
stuff in my community all the time and
I'm like dude shut the [__] up stick to
politics
yeah they're like they're like very mad
at me but yeah well the thing is Dragon
Ball fans are some of the most
passionate fans you can find oh yeah so
we love clowning on Dragon Ball fans
maybe a bit too much uh sometimes
actually I mean it's so easy yeah it was
my first like actual anime that I
watched that I really got into anime
with yeah Dragon Ball and Dragon Ball Z
yeah and
um I you know I I rewatched it I tried
re-watching it recently thinking like oh
this is gonna be sick and then I
realized like oh as a kid when I was
watching it
I was basically making up most of the
fights because in my mind it was like a
puzzle piece that was missing that was
my own imagination yeah because like
when you're a kid you're like thinking
oh this is so well drawn yeah and then
you watch it and they're reusing assets
like crazy like the punches oh yeah yeah
yeah and and in my mind I'm thinking
they're like throwing blows and like
dodging you know what I mean turns out
like that wasn't the case at all and
then a fight sequence was like 11
episodes yeah yeah you have like five
episodes of just them powering up yeah
yeah and then you're like two episodes
are staring down yeah and you're like as
a kid this felt like 20 30 minutes yeah
it was like 30 episodes or something
yeah how much skipping is like allowed
until you're basically just not watching
it at that point because I feel like if
you wanted to skim through it and just
skip through it's like I guess the
Dragon Ball yeah it's very hard to stop
at any point and feel like you're
getting content right so it'll just like
spread out yeah so yeah I mean I we've
talked about Dragon Ball Z quality on
this podcast and uh I you know it's it
has its lineage it started a lot of
Shonen anime it's [__] incredible I
would not re-watch Dragon Ball Z yeah no
I mean it was literally my entry point
in anime the first ever anime I actually
watched was dubbed in turkey when I was
growing up oh [__] subasa
um
yeah oh yeah and I don't really like
soccer like that I don't really you know
I don't really [__] with football and um
but because turkey loves football they
probably thought like this is a sick
[__] this is a sick show to like
distribute yeah yeah um and it was
dubbed it was dubbed in Turkish right
okay and I did not like it at all so I
just never really watched any anime
because I thought it was all like random
soccer
and thank God for Dragon Ball it like
brought me back in was was the anime
scene big in Turkey did you get a lot of
exposure to anime I wouldn't imagine so
like I didn't even understand the
distinction between anime and like
Western rides Western animated shows
yeah at all like I just thought it was
another drawn show with like weird eyes
well because it was probably all on like
the same channel as like all the other
Western cartoons yeah yeah yeah exactly
and growing up when I was watching it
you I like obviously maybe some Western
consuming my own shows targeted towards
me it definitely felt like they were
really different and you couldn't really
pinpoint why yeah dumb kids yeah you
understand the concept of dubbing yeah
dubbing just seems like magic yeah yeah
other languages exist no no no no no
well there wasn't that much like um I'm
thinking about it now there wasn't
exactly like a lot of Turkish cartoons
anyway so like everything is dubbed yeah
um so for me like I said I just thought
it was like a little bit different yeah
it was the same thing and then I
realized when I came to America and like
saw all this like different branching
out between anime and and you know
that's when I realized like oh this is
totally sick yeah yeah what was the
anime you watched after Dragon Ball Z
then
I mean I don't know I
ones that are most memorable and are all
also in my top anime so probably like
Cowboy Bebop and Samurai okay yeah a lot
of stuff I watched I watched off of when
I came to America in a summer or
something because like there's no anime
when I was growing up in Turkey yeah at
all yeah except for to Tsubasa for some
reason
um
so uh it was all it was all like what is
it called Toonami it's like tsunami I
don't swim yeah yeah it's also in
tsunami stuff yeah so whatever they had
on at night that's what I kind of got
into
um but you know so when did you actually
start getting into anime and don't say
you're not don't say you're not because
I mean I so I I read like uh I read the
Naruto mangas when they would uh come
out like in America when I was in
America in the summer certified weave
right there yeah all right the fact that
you went to the manga yeah yeah yeah
well because for me it was like I love
this content it's so unique it's so
different and I can't get it in Turkey
so like I would go to I would park up at
like a borders yeah literally I would go
to like a Borders or a Barnes and Noble
and I was like oh damn like you could
just like sit here all day and just read
these books yeah like that's crazy
because like at the time I'm old I'm I'm
you know I'm 31 years old so like at the
time I didn't even really think about
how I could like like we didn't have
access to distribution networks like we
do now you know you got lime wire and
[__] but like yeah that's half the time
you're downloading malware on the family
computer yeah yeah so I didn't know
um I didn't I didn't know how to like
access it so I would just like consume
it as much as I could yeah you got what
you took uh yeah yeah and uh yeah that
was that was very similar if you tried
downloading anime offline wire most of
the time it was just oh yeah yeah most
of the time it was either out of order
or hentai it was Bill Clinton or Bill
Clinton yeah a lot of Bill Clinton yeah
it was yeah I I also never really got
into digital uh I can't do the digital
reading like it has to be I don't know
it has to be physical I'm exactly the
same yeah it's just for some reason it
doesn't hit for me yeah it used to I
used to be like physical only and I
think reading on a tablet has like
offset that a bit I cannot read on a
phone phone is like way too small of a
screen
is like a lot of manga don't get adapted
nearly quick enough like Jojo for
example in English is like I think
they're just starting part five oh [__]
already the official English translation
geez we have like part five dub of the
anime before we had part five English in
the manga that's so weird because I
don't know why I don't know why it's
taking so long like distribution
probably a bigger audience how does it's
insane that it takes that long oh in the
case of Jojo they're probably reading
and they're just like what the [__] is
this like how the hell the hell am I
supposed to translate is this allowed
it's like [__] we gotta we gotta they
have like board meetings for how to
change the band names
this is copyright infringement the manga
oh yeah how does that work in Japan like
they just they don't care about like
Western copy right they just run it I
think they just kind of like turn the
Blind Eye maybe in a lot of ways I don't
think it's more so that the American one
would have a problem I think it's just
more of a like it's a it's just a just
do it just in case like change it yeah
because why why even risk it because
there's so many band names where it's
like maybe it feels warm we could maybe
let it slide yeah but when the whole
show has like Pink Floyd
the Rolling Stone it's like all right
yeah yeah I'm honestly surprised there
hasn't been a band that has found JoJo
on a whim and just being like that we
didn't we didn't give them permission to
do this like what what the [__] I mean
it would be super [__] lame if you
were like yeah I don't want it in that
it's literally the coolest thing ever or
they find it and they start reading
they're like oh this is actually kind of
sick yeah
you don't want to piss off JoJo fans
because holy [__]
and burn it down you know